[Music]
are you looking to figure out how to
make a new car key and remote for your
Toyota por Runner well I've got a
solution for you this is going to work
on 2010 through 2021 4Runners and lots
of other vehicles so be sure to visit
tomsk key.com and see if we can't help
you get another car ke remote for a
whole lot less than it costed the
dealership got had a friend reason they
call it dealership and they want to
charge aote or $400 for a new key in
remote it was ridiculous instead of that
you can go to tomy.com place in order
and will rent you this car key
programming device uh we also Char the
deposit be sure it get sent back after
you programed your key we're also
sending new key that you need and
everything to make it quick and easy and
even include the free return mailing
label your back now if your vehicle has
a push button start that uses a keyless
smart fob like this don't worry we've
got you covered with that as well all
right the first thing we need to do is
get this cable plugged into the OBD2
port look up you're going to find a plug
like this almost always it's white on
some Vehicles it may be up in this area
usually it's under by the brake pedal
simply plug it
in and we're ready so let's take a look
at our uh can remote here's the working
one you notice the remotes are working
just
[Music]
great and here's the new
one doesn't work at all we're going to
set this up here
here to
program you're going to take Tom's car
key programmer this is model
tsl2 and when you plug it
in be sure you screw it in on this side
you're going to find some
lights notice the Bluetooth light is lit
up as red we need to get that blue by
connecting to the
phone with the programmer rental we
include a phone that is already to make
your programming process easy the
programmer will show a red light at
first fire up the app and the programmer
light turns blue when the device and
phone have paired all right you see it's
turned blue so we're connected this is
good so once it's paired once it's
activated then we're going to go into
immobilization
here don't need to download and set up
some information we're going to do the
remote first
remote now at this point you got to take
your working key put it into the
ignition turn it two clicks to the on
position one
two you can see some lights on the
dashboard up here now we need to connect
so sometimes you can tell which which
you need but the easiest way if you
can't aren't sure just start at type one
you'll hear a very faint click it's
going to try to connect and it'll fail
if it's not the correct one for your
vehicle so that failed to connect try
type two now it clicks and it's popped
open has the ability to erase remotes
and program remotes you can erase
remotes if you'd like that'll erase any
remotes that out in the world for your
vehicle so if you bought it used things
like that you could do it when you erase
the remote it'll follow a very similar
step it's programming remote we're just
going to go right into program here
tells us to switch the vehicle to on
position so I'm going to turn it off and
then two clicks to the on position again
just to reset things and open the
driver's
door so I've opened the driver's door
now once I do that hit yes then you get
the key I need to
program it's trying to
communicate says to press the lock and
unlock button for one second and then
press the lock button so take this
listen for a beep
you may need to repeat this a few
times right hear that
beep it's
[Music]
programmed programming success
occasionally it'll say success even if
it was not successful give it another
try so let's make sure this works just
pulled this out watch the lock here
locked
unlock
lock the
alarm Okay my working one worked as well
so that's how you program the new
remote okay when you go to program a new
key the first thing to check is whether
you have a master key or valet
key now valet key from Toyota often has
a gray head but not all the time way you
can tell find your blinking red light in
this 4Runner it's right over here it can
be Elsewhere on the dashboard it can be
up near the the speedometer sometimes
it's over on the far side of the
steering wheel or up on the very top but
in this case it's right over here when
we take our master key and slide it in
the ignition watch the blinking red
light it turned off immediately and sto
blinking pull it out the blinking starts
again this is a valet
key now watch the blinking red light
when this goes in it'll turn on stay on
for a couple seconds see how it's on
then it turned off that lets you know
you have valet key if you have valet key
you cannot program a new car key and
it's important to note that on a key
like this with a remote there's two
things to program both the buttons are
one and then the chip that lets the
engine start is the other so be sure you
have a master key so to program our new
key you've seen that this is the master
key watch the blinking red light when
this new one goes in notice we haven't
cut this yet slide it in the light's
still
blinking the chip isn't programmed so
this key even if it's cut isn't going to
start the
vehicle but program it take your master
key plug it in turn it two clicks to the
on
position now come back to your app
remember we're still still have the blue
um light showing it's on blue tooth
connection you need to move back till
you get to this
page if you go all the way back to home
screen
[Music]
immobilization and then
immobilizer once we're in
immobilizer now there's several
different choices usually you can tell
if you have a d chip or a g chip or an H
chip in this case this key is a g chip
the Toyota master has the letter G
stamped right there on the metal
blade not if it's an aftermarket key it
doesn't always have that stamp on it all
right we're going to select type Three G
chip 2011 through
2015 this actually works on 2010 through
2021 4 Runners we're working to add more
there's a few different options you want
to stay away from the engine reset
things like that that'll cause you
problems you can erase some lost keys if
you've got lost keys out there it'll
walk you right through it it's quite
simple it's very similar similar to what
we're going to do today and that's
adding a new key if you have too many
keys out there you'll need to erase lost
keys because you can only program four
or five keys on most
Toyotas okay we're going to click add a
key tells us we need a master key we
already confirmed we've got a master key
hit yes all right it says insert the
program master key switch to the on
position that's two clicks one two hit
yes to continue now I want you to watch
where the blinking red light is when we
hit yes it's going to turn on
solid okay see how it's solid that means
it's ready to insert the key that we
need to
program here's our key to be programmed
so we're going to pull out the working
key going to put this in and watch that
red light starts
blinking now it's going to take 60
seconds in order
program so notice the blinking pattern
it's blinking at about one blink every 1
second and that'll continue the whole 60
seconds if you look at it Clos and it's
blinking differently like it might have
a couple fast blinks a pause three fast
blinks pause that's a sign of something
else that is a problem with programming
process so we can help you through help
at tomsk key.com there's also frequently
asked questions on the website that can
help solve common issues now we're
approaching 60 seconds so watch that
blinking red light it'll stop blinking
when the programming is done there we go
it's
finished now we can take out our
key on our app wait for the security
light turn off program is complete hit
okay
and we're done it was that easy so how
do you check that this is programmed
remember a blinking red light slide it
in and it turns
off pull it out the light's blinking
before you can use your new spare key
you need to get your keyblade cut to
match your existing key to do that you
can either run all over town trying to
find some place to cut it or you can add
our key by photo key cutting service
during checkout it's super easy Once you
place your order you just take three
pictures of your keyblade go ahead and
make sure your phone is directly above
the key so we can see the cuts properly
you'll upload those photos after
completing checkout on our website then
we'll cut your keyblade so your new
spare key arrives cut all ready to fit
your vehicle our key by photo key
cutting service is really cool saves you
a ton of time and money and quite
frankly we think it's pretty amazing so
that's it that's how how easy it is
program new car key and remote for you
now you might consider protecting your
investment we sell these little tile key
finders it connects to your smartphone
and you'll always know where your keys
are at even if you leave them somewhere
they fall out of your pocket you'll be
able to find it too if someone else with
the app on their phone walks by your
lost Keys it'll pick it up and notify
you where they were
at now as you put things back in the box
we appreciate it if you turn the phone
that we ship with it all the way off
that'll just save battery to make it
easier for the next person so it doesn't
have to get charged there you see just
how easy it is to make yourself a new
key and remote and save a bunch of money
in the process we provide a 100% full
money back guarantee so if it doesn't
work out for your vehicle for any reason
we'll give you all your money back it's
that simple just be sure to let us know
and ask tell us what's going on so we
can try and help get it working go visit
tomsk key.com where you can order your
key and remote when you've got
everything finished put the programmer
back in the Box put the cable back in
and will have included a prepaid free
mailing label so you just put in the Box
put the mailing label on send it back
and we'll refund that deposit once it
arrives back at our offices if you can't
find what you need visit the other
vehicle section where you can leave your
email and the vehicle you're looking for
if you still need assistance visit help.
tomsk key.com thanks so much for
watching please be sure to leave a
comment let people know about our great
customer service and have a great day